please to have Dan please act back on
the program how are you Dan grab John
Goodrich I love that guy I love that Jeb
Ken Roosevelt maybe how to just post a
video I don't know go no I wouldn't call
that a jab Dan I'm just suggesting
though what everybody oh yeah you know
what this is going to be a wild trade
deadline I really think I think there's
like four guys rich that are going to be
in play I think what Sonny gray I think
we're hearing a lot that he's being
linked to the Yankees that that's kind
of the Yankees guy I think you Darvish
could be on the move
I think Zach Britton could be on the
move and I think another guy that the
race looks so good a week ago they
finally win last night I'm not sure if
they're in or they're out and Chris
Archer is a guy if I still think the
team that needs to go out the most to
get a pitcher is the Dodgers I'm a
little worried about Clayton Kershaw on
this back issue it bothered him last
year he's missed some time and I don't
know about you rich but when I think of
the Dodgers and I think of them a whole
lot better I take them a lot more
serious with Clayton Kershaw if you
could tell me if you had a crystal ball
rich and you could tell me that he's
going to be back at the end of August
and he's going to be in full swing and
no restrictions I mean I think the
Dodgers can get to the World Series if
not I'm worried like hell for the
Dodgers I guess I agree with you I just
if you could tell me that you could
really trust Alex wood and Rich Hill and
Game one and Game two of Kershaw wasn't
ready but boy I don't that's just my
personal opinion that's it I look at the
Dodgers different without Clayton
Kershaw well let's just assume that
Kershaw is back and they add Verlander
right Kershaw Verlander along with wood
and Rich Hill that that that's that's
all she wrote or that or or maybe they
had written to the backend and do kind
of what the Yankees did a couple of
weeks ago which is add arms to the
backend so the front end is shorter yeah
I think what's going to be a little
difficult with Verlander he's old 28
million next year in the following year
so you're on the hook for almost 60
million and listen there aren't a lot of
teams the Dodgers maybe one team that
could eat some of that money this is a
problem if you're the Tigers rich what
we're seeing is day and age at trading
right now if you're expecting to get a
lot of prospects back then you're going
to have to eat a lot of that
but if you want to just say hey we'd
like Verlander and we're going to give
you a couple of prospects package you're
gonna they're not good then you're going
to have to eat a whole lot of money
that's just the weight trading business
is right now like you got a twenty eight
million dollar price tag and if you
expect it you're going to get something
really back from the Dodgers then boy if
you're the Tigers you're going to say
we're going to eat over half of that and
then you may get something back but if a
team like the Dodgers are just going to
take on that contract you're getting
nothing back so you know I guess I got
to tell you Dan I'm a damn pleased sack
of the MLB Network look it's not my
money but if I'm a Tigers and I'm
sitting there seven games out of the
wild-card eight and a half in first
place you've already sent JD Martinez
packing to Arizona then I am going to
just say okay look we made these moves
we made these decisions let's eat the
money and let's get as many prospects as
we can for Verlander and Miguel Cabrera
send him out - and Kinsler and just just
raise it down to the ground get all
these kids back and start building some
for the Old English day in Detroit
that's what I would do rich I couldn't
grow any more and you know what's sad we
could go back about six or seven years
ago and they've tried could you imagine
if they would have had a kenley jansen
and a roll this Chapman away Davis if if
the Tigers would have had a dependable
guy in the ninth inning the last six or
seven years they would have won at least
one World Series and probably two and
they've tried to fix it they had
poppagrande they went out and got Joe
Nathan they brought in k-rod they went
every offseason to try to fix the
ninth-inning to get the best guy that
was out there there's just a fungus in
that bullpen rich and I and I really
believe that like there are some teams
that third base has just been a hole for
some organizations right and that has
been the case with the Tigers with their
bullpen they have yet to find a guy and
I think the window it shut it's closed
they're not going to be in the
postseason this year and I agree with
you it's time to look for five to six
years down the road and just kind of if
you're going to go this direction and
let JD Martinez who is one of their
better younger players go then I think
the rest have to start going - yeah just
let it all go
I mean but but it's a damn plea sack of
MLB Network joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show it's tough to turn to a fan
base and say
we're three well I mean what the Tigers
are seven out they ma but it's got to be
tough to turn we're fanbase and say
we're within three games of wild card
and and we just decide you know what
we're gonna we're gonna send you Darvish
packing if you're Texas or yeah you know
what we're just going to send I guess
that that would be the one that you're
taught or is that written you know
you're four and a half out for the for
the O's yeah but you know what always
though I think you know what we've
talked about this rich you and I with
the last four or five years we're
waiting like when is this starting
pitching really going to bring them down
right we keep going how do they keep
doing it their Bolton is great they've
got Britain they've got a day you know
they got Givens they've got Brock and
all this but you know what we've we've
been the last four or five years going
how the hell are they doing this they're
staying in it with their patching these
guys together
filming in Bondi and gozman finally
found his way around a little bit now
but it's caught up to them they just
don't have this starting pitching and I
think the thing you got to be careful of
what we're such in this mode of like
tearing everything down tear it down and
build it because that's the way it works
but you know what you have to have rich
you better have a Kris Bryant you better
have an Anthony Rizzo and you better
have a Wilson Contreras you better have
players that step up you better have a
Korea
you better have Springer and you better
have they'll tuve because you can tear
down and build up and say this is what
we're going to do and a lot of teams
have tried to do that but boy the guys
that you get backs like the white sox
yan Moncada the guy that gives they got
back that's the big piece for the white
socks and if he doesn't hit rich i think
the white sox are being the same boat
now that they're going to be in five
years from now and that's just a
mediocre franchise those guys have to
hit the franchise changers and Bryant
and Rizzo have been that and Addison
Russell for the Cubs Stan please sack of
MLB Network again they're going to have
full deadline day coverage on Monday and
then going to Cooperstown for the
Baseball Hall of Fame in shrine ceremony
that includes Bud Selig and I know
obviously you've got a long history with
with Bud Selig being a Milwaukee Brewer
your all-star
years with the with the Brewers he was
the owner of the team and then he became
commissioner of the sport and I know you
were also very involved with the labor
union Dan are there mixed feelings about
pod door yeah there are because you know
what I was
player rep like what happened rich on my
second year in the big leagues right and
nobody wants to be the player rep
because we're going back now in the
mid-80s and that's when you know you
were front and center and all of a
sudden you're in a blue-collar town like
Milwaukee right I'm 26 years old I have
two years in the big leagues and all of
a sudden I'm the player rep but
everybody in Milwaukee is blue-collar as
it gets I'm getting ripped and bashed in
the newspaper these guys are waiting and
looking for more money but then it's
guys like Paul Molitor Robin Yount
Gorman Thomas Cecil Cooper you know
we've got to stick up for the old guys
and we've got to do all this it was a
really tough spot and I was a young guy
and you know having to deal with that
and getting called into the office with
Bud Selig and hey what's going on with a
lockout what are you guys going to do is
this serious and you could put a really
tough spot and you know I tell you what
I do have to laugh though because if you
would have told me rich in 1986 87 86
was my rookie year that Bud Selig was
eventually going to be the commissioner
baseball nobody in a million years would
believe it right he was the owner of the
of the Brewers car salesman guy and I
didn't realize until my second year in
the big leagues he used to walk the
catwalk across county stadium like in
the eighth and ninth inning and I never
do this till one day he told me you make
me a nervous wreck when you come in in
the ninth inning some time I'm like I
start pacing back and forth and one
night rich like in the middle of 88
season I took my last warm-up right
one-run lead and I look up there and
there you go it's pacing back and forth
and from that time on I started get
nervous rich because he made me nervous
pacing back and forth so there are mixed
feelings you know big feelings yes
yeah cuz I guess again I there is for me
to be very honest with you you know and
and and obviously the wild card the
advent of it was something that he
fought for and here we are talking about
all these teams that have a shot right
now in the middle of the season if there
was no wild card then there would be
such a lack of interest so that does
deserve to get all the kudos for because
as a traditionalist I thought to myself
this stinks I did you know but it hasn't
proved and I like what baseball has done
to get two teams in in a 1-1 game
playoff sort of like I remember in my
youth the Yankees in the and the Red Sox
playing that one game
by off that led to Bucky Dent there are
some great moments that could come out
of that but then that that that 95
season
I mean 94 season I mean right how how
can that guy be led into the Hall of
Fame is well you know you know what you
know I think when you look back at it I
think he was under tremendous pressure I
don't think Bud Selig actually you know
maybe he was the face of everything but
I think behind that were George
Steinbrenner and Jerry Reinsdorf and and
I think you know somebody had to be the
spokesman for that group of tough owners
and that's why it's such a tough job and
that's why not a lot of people wanted to
do it and Bud Selig had to be the bad
guy he was the bad guy the fall guy
and a lot of people knock about the
steroid era like that listen everybody
kind of knew did he turn his back Sosa
McGwire did they say baseball did they
hurt baseball you know Kings had to know
ever and you know the bottom line is I
don't know what's right what's wrong but
I do know this I agree with you 100% I
was so against the wild card I'm
thinking you know what why do you want
to water it down and dilute it if
there's something about the four
division winners and expansion but you
know what it's proven to be the best
thing because if not September to be
awful boring right now particularly now
when you have a you know like the
Nationals are blown away the Astros are
runaway winners the Dodgers are runaway
winners there'd be like two compelling
divisions right now the NL and Al
central net would be about it you're
right I mean the Seattle Texas and the
Angels are are are 17 18 and 18 a half
games out of first place right now but
they're in it exactly they're in exactly
and we're going to be talking about the
Diamondbacks we're going to be talking
about the Rockies the Pirates are back
in the mid Cardinals might get hot then
we're going to talk about 15 teams in
the month of September where if this
wasn't the case back the old way we'd be
talking about well four teams are gone
already and cold out and we'd be talking
about six total teams well before you
join Dan in the commercial break between
hours one and two I'm sorry that I was
pacing the Rich Eisen show floor nervous
about your appearance I'm sorry that's
all right rich you and me anytime okay
hey you got it take care of thanks for
the call but Stan please sack no the MLB
Network at please sack 19 on Twitter so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy